meet Germany's new cabinet they might be
in charge of the country but basically
they're just like you and me a bunch of
average folks
Angela Merkel and her team a microcosm
of German society but are they no not
really
let's start with the women there are too
few of them in the government's new
lineup six in order to reflect current
demographics there should be nine I'll
find it it's striking that there are no
women from the CSU this could be
problematic in the long run because
there is a basic expectation that at
least there needs to be a gender balance
i Nick Amazon Australia test the second
problem the cabinet is a little too
pious only two thirds of Germans a
Christian but every single one of
Germany's federal ministers is religious
I'd an others although she's not a
minister but Commissioner for
integration is a Muslim thanks to the
Environment Minister Merkel's cabinet
does accurately reflect Germany's
straight gay ratio but with an average 2
per capita Merkel's ministers have too
many children the German average is 1.4
they're also too keen on marriage 90
percent of them have husbands or wives
but not even half of Germans are married
and just for the record of those who are
one in five has been unfaithful bombs on
to Daddy Pasha politicians be an
exception and it has to be said that
they tend to spend extremely long
periods away from their family since in
Isaac Fong Familia
ooh-la-la our German politicians more
like their French counterparts than we
realize
when it comes to where they live they're
certainly a lot more modest forget the
alizée palace Chancellor Merkel lives in
a humble apartment our leaders aren't
sealed away from reality in palaces or
ranches personally I think that's a very
good thing about German politicians that
they live the same way as the general
public
that's ecclesia niya under Perkins int
so in that respect they are like you and
me they ride bikes enjoy a drink and
even the Chancellor's holidays are as
likely as ours to turn into a disaster